Hi everybody,
I'm here with Nick Nixon.
Just did the podcast for the first time.
It was incredible.
It was amazing.
Now the drive back is going to be not that bad.
It won't be bad now.
No,
it's perfect.
There's no traffic right now going well,
it might be a little.
It's actually 6:00.
Yeah,
it's actually rush hour,
but usually people are going the opposite direction and I go,
well actually they're kind of going everywhere right now,
tonight before holidays.
So people done son,
Echo Park.
Oh,
I can give you better directions.
Yeah,
there is a way to avoid a lot of shit.
That's what I thought it was going to get.
A sneaky little way that you can avoid to leave here.
I'm going to move even further away from here.
I've looked at and I liked it.
I looked at some places.
I want to move them.
I want to get a house in the mountains.
I would love to.
I want to get a house in Lake Arrowhead,
hour out or whatever.
That's what I'm talking about.
It's amazing up there.
So Sam,
we can relax and bring benches and there's weird she bought them to deliver
around that.
There's a lot of interesting cats up there and so anywhere you live in the
mountains,
you live in the mountains,
living with people that are living around nature.
You got to live around interesting people and for sure they got strong,
strong,
strong mountains.
We have that here though too.
We definitely have a lack of strong strongly.
In fact,
sometimes the wait is too strong,
you know,
I forgot what we were.
Um.
Oh Canada,
no,
England,
England.
We had some weed in England and I was like,
this is really good weed.
It's not too strong.
It's like I don't feel like I want roller kit.
Like Roller Skates Hash.
No,
it was weed,
but it was like,
it wasn't like,
you know,
some California where it is so hard.
It's so stony.
It's so powerful that you kind of just like,
you get hit with any like,
Whoa,
I gotta manage this.
You know your mind in terms of job.
Yeah.
It's like,
but whereas with this weed it was silly.
We'd was like,
you hit it,
you felt high,
you felt good,
but you didn't feel too fucked up and it took like four hits not to like two
minutes of California.
Are you adjusting to a different atmosphere?
Yeah.
And you want to talk about.
I think Seattle's depressing.
Yeah.
I've never.
I've only spent a night in England,
a mentor.
Did you do stand up there?
People are great.
The grant,
we did a UFC there too.
The people are really nice people.
Some of the most polite people.
I really smart as well,
but man,
the weather is oppressing whether it seems like that fall,
foggy and raining every day and
that too.
Yeah,
they don't have that.
American dental son.
Wga,
their dental bills.
Nick,
you're a road warrior.
How many days a year do you travel?
A.
I'd probably only on the road,
like maybe half the year.
Maybe.
Really important.
Yeah,
because I go off and on because I write in town to get writing and you stay in
town and then he just started doing stand up on the felon.
Yeah,
fill in time.
Shizam bitches.
They heard it.
That's how he runs his life and you could find nick on twitter.
It's nic k a t h e.
that's exactly how.
Find funding and I'm verified.
So you,
that's how you know.
It's really mean.
I would imagine we're making video powerful.
Hold on us or was a today Donald Trump,
another hilarious podcast.
Man,
we haven't done that.
Otherwise we're dead.
We need to do it like once a month.
I'd love to keep to keep figuring out a way to avoid this.
This is what we have to do.
We have to do a steady one of these because I think one a month is perfect for
us to have a shitload of things that we haven't talked to each other,
you know,
because we talked so much about the,
on the phone about things and we see each other clubs about things that
sometimes a lot of stuff gets like tread to the point where we can't bring it up
organically in front of each other anymore because we already talked about that.
So when you're talking about on the podcast doesn't come out as seamlessly.
So we have like one month between podcasts.
We built up a lot of good shit.
Yeah,
we do.
It's good.
It's been a month since the last one about right.
I've been fucking around with this bit.
Well,
I can't tell.
I can't tell you.
It's not ready yet.
I'll tell you after we're done with this.
You can't know yet.
Someday be.
It's going to be a good bit.
It's doing really well right now,
but needs some work.
I just want to talk to my friend.
I'm going to go to Chicago or you guys.
Interesting.
I
go to the Chicago theater and it will be lots of foreign firm.
We are bringing a party.
We're bringing Joey Diaz and Dunkin and you know what it is what it is.
It is a big fat fucking comedy party.
That's what it's going to be.
It's going to be a good time.
The Chicago theater is awesome.
Um,
we're having the UFC Wayne's there that same night,
so the way it's going to be there at 4:00 and we're going to have a show there
at eight.
It's called.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
And it's fun because when I was looking for theaters in Chicago,
um,
we uh,
tried to get this theater and they said that someone has a hold on it for that
day.
I'm like,
well fuck,
let's fine,
let's challenge the whole.
It's finding a whole lose the UFC fairly.
So I knew the UFC was going to be out of there by 6:00.
They're done.
And then we come in at eight to house bitch.
And I haven't been to Chicago in a long time.
The last time was,
there was actually my 40th birthday.
I've never been.
Remember we had that crazy birthday cake.
Right.
Great comedy came from Chicago.
Chicago's a great comedy town.
You know what?
It's a comedy town that much like Boston was at one point in time,
a great comments on.
And that was a little bit deprived.
You know,
there's,
there's not that much there anymore.
There's a few clubs that have died off or something made comics coming out of
Chicago.
You know,
when kids start out there,
they try to get out of there and go somewhere with a scene.
No,
there's a few scenes left in the country.
Denver is,
in my opinion,
one of the big ones.
Underrated,
underrated,
under appreciated.
Seeing.
Oh,
Denver.
It's fucking great.
You know what else has got a good scene in Atlanta?
That's great.
Can,
it's going to seem.
And the fucking the um.
Oh,
the other place.
So the Jesus Christ,
the place that I was going to.
What?
Sarah Club?
I don't know.
Only to the punchline.
Punchlines cars.
How can I remember that?
No.
So many names.
The chuckle hut,
the fuck factory,
the fucking giggle house.
But the punchline is amazing club.
That place is super old school and it's really a museum.
It's just like the ice house when you walk around and see shit on the wall.
That's called Holy Shit.
This is like,
you know,
as a headshot from 1980.
This is the punchline,
the laughing skull man because it's this compact like fucking Bentley Room style
underground club.
And like it's a great thing to see I think like 100 and that sounds like the
perfect place to go to,
to work on new material.
I can love it man.
It's beautiful club events right under this cool bar,
the vortex.
So it's like,
I mean when I go there and man,
it's really bad because it's endless beer and like,
dude,
let's go together.
I'd love to.
Oh,
that'd be so fun.
I'm going to do that right after I filmed my next special because when I fell my
next special,
the first thing I'm going to do is go on a rampage of small club.
So after that I don't know.
I'm going there and I'm booked again for like the summer,
but we should fucking be so fun to hang out there
window from the time I record specialist at the time I'd actually air still like
you have to come up with a lot of new fucking material so I'm going to want to
go on the road a lot right after it airs.
I'm going on a long before,
you know,
because I only have like three or four months to really come up with them on a
new shit.
It's,
it's tricky,
you know,
but those small places like the place we're going to be out this weekend,
the Pasadena Ice House,
we're in the annex,
which is a really awesome room.
It is a really rare opportunity to see comedy in like about as intimate and
environment that you're ever gonna.
See Doug Benson,
Joey Diaz,
me,
Pablo Francisco.
It's,
it's,
it's about as intimate as you get and we do them there all the time and you can
get that podcast that we do from there as well on desk squad on itunes and it's
called the ice house chronicle.
So what we do is while the show is going on,
a podcast is also going on,
so one guy's on stage and five guys and girls or whatever are in this room and
they're all talking shit and it's hilarious.
It's comics hanging out.
It's a real green room.
It's a green room where it's like,
the way it's set up is you know about as ideal as you can get.
Super Cool weed friendly comedy club.
You know the,
the bar is called the bartenders.
Cool.
Exactly.
The ruins an awesome five small
and it always sells out and it's packed with podcast fans.
So if you want to check that,
do you want to check that out too?
So.
Alright,
that's it.
Dante.
Right.
So it's good to see you buddy.
Do you need.
Do you need anything man?
I'm.
Oh I have two flashlights on.
Cool.
Alright.
Give me some knuckles.
Stable was feeding
this table is better now because it's got a new cloth.
So balls have fallen easier until it breaks in.
Done another really fun podcast.
Brian,
did you enjoy it?
Yes.
Prophet Ron Paul Shark.
I have about 100 of them because when I said that I wanted to uh,
where Ron Paul shirt on the tonight show.
Everybody got me.
Ron Paul shirts including Alex Jones sent two boxes.
Two boxes or Ron Paul shirts.
So you can have some Ron Paul shirts to Brian Sweet.
Like some Alex Jones.
Okay.
I got one.
We're hanging out with my friend Aubrey who used to be Chris and it's the only
friend that I tolerate a change their name and what else?
I'm like get the fuck Outta here.
I can't change your name.
I bought.
I've been persistent and you can change your name as long.
Isn't it?
Incorporate.
It's become.
If it's psychedelically inspired,
I allow a certain amount of leniency.
It was already my middle name.
It's not like you made up a name.
I am sunflower,
right?
I'm apple.
Your thermal change your name?
I did red band.
That's right.
You did.
Good point.
I want to show everybody that fucking super sexy fanny pack your rock and that.
His debts,
that Syrup Syrup Fanny packs that sort of makes a hemp gear.
They make a hemp geek that I wear as well and they've decided to make a
fanny pack when it's so big.
It's like a backpack that I use it for a camera bag in one way.
It's pretty fucking killer though.
I'm going to use it for traveling I think because it's tough,
but hemp is amazing material man.
I mean I really should have made my tee shirts at a half,
but it would have been even more expensive than the ones that I have now.
I like the highest.
The higher primates shirts,
highest quality cotton.
I could get and really thin light ponds,
so it's like real comfortable,
but people were like,
Make Hampshire.
It's probably isn't move because happens a superior form of cloth.
It's just much stronger.
I like him.
Shirts,
tee shirts.
My Ge mad shrunk like crazy.
That whole shit bamboos.
And another good one too.
It's easy to grow again.
You can get really good bamboo sheets.
Bedsheets using those for a long time.
Also,
towels,
rugs naturally antimicrobial as well.
So maybe have bamboo grows fast.
It's fun.
Show about,
um,
them taking bamboo and using it to make houses because you chop it up and you
know,
use the fibers of and they make a cardboard or plywood and have this bamboo
fiber.
But it grows like nothing.
It's all of you watching.
Yeah.
What a fucking plan.
And they use it for um,
uh,
occasionally use it for pool cues as well.
Some guys have been doing that recently because the strength of bamboo compare
to the strength of other woods,
like through the roof on that kind of line,
that vertical line apparently in the this splice it and compile it.
And when you make a pool cue here,
but it has like a fucking,
like a crazy hit to.
It felt like extra spring to.
It just totally makes sense.
We're about to do some manly shit right now.
Play Pool.
Brian played pool with me a couple times,
but since then he's learned that have considered it.
I considered poor two totally different things,
right,
Brian?
Yes.
What's the difference?
You're addicted.
You're,
you're,
you're hardcore about it.
Like you do a hundred games in a night where I'm used to like,
hey,
we'll just have some beer and play a couple games of pool.
You're now at the bar.
You're like,
let's play 100 games and let's be there for five.
Eight till five minutes.
Doesn't even lock until about game seven,
dash seven.
That's when he gets out and you're in fucking trouble.
I got to steal a few games early.
Otherwise be a bad night.
Although now my hair is my wife.
My wife was a friend that will delete photos.
You can't let her have a camera
in it.
Yeah.
She just deleted all the pictures that don't delete that.
They call you the next day and say,
did you delete facebook?
I used to scour my tags and be like,
don't care,
like whatever.
I want to look ugly 20 percent of the time.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Good.
Eighty percent average.
Can't worry about what you look like,
your photos.
Don't worry about what you actually look like.
You know,
write him.
If you look good in real life and they got a picture of you like bronchitis guys
don't care.
Like Brian,
there's a million pictures of you.
How many photos of you or they give us the faith.
Literally thousands of pictures that still going on now.
I stopped it,
stopped doing it too much and then I just found myself always doing it.
When I was around Joseph,
I was like,
all right.
People just don't ask for it though.
People do ask for the fish.
I video
do it and behind it
and ruin the pictures and you probably do like a thousand,
right?
Right.
More than that,
more than the balance of this conversation.
There's two of us filming.
One of them is we're all just got to get used to the lights.
Rhonda Bright Lights.
This is what's gonna happen.
They're gonna be a bunch of TMZ.
Cameras.
So you.
Who Do you want to find out?
Who's next for Misha?
Misha.
That's the one you want to fight?
Her boyfriend,
boyfriend.
Brian.
What is that?
Just the ultimate shits.
It seemed like a really nice guy.
That's what you actually know.
The guy he fought in a
very nice guy.
Nice.
I'm just trying to like Brian up.
What was his name?
However you say his last name?
Tate Tate.
Pat Frank tape.
Oh Shit.
Okay.
Yeah.
Wow.
You don't like it?
I do like them both.
I think they're both.
Both variously.
I don't think they like me very much.
It seemed like you're very nice person but you should very competitive.
Very competitive with everything.
I'll have to like eat,
like if we were eating lunch together and I try to finish my lunch before you.
Whoa.
It's like everything that's weird.
Yeah.
That's my like if I know I'm not good at it then screw it.
I don't care.
Like Michael Jordan,
Michael Jordan and game of checkers.
He fucking hates.
Especially shit.
He's trying to like pull,
apparently beat him at pool.
He doesn't want to talk to you
like depressing lows in like I hate.
I get a pool or something.
Then you don't want to play me because it's so slow.
The other person talks.
Shifting your time.
It makes it worse if you lose it and someone's talking to you,
you know,
but I can't make fun of a lot for losing pool.
I think it's better to be good at jumping people in their heads.
Like all my talent has got funneled into one area and like any sport with a
ball,
I just can't do it.
Start doing judo twice a week.
I teach
dynamics in the way
it's like on Santa Monica Boulevard between like Barrington and Monday.
Oh cool.
I got to go down there.
I want.
I want to train with Antony Dutch kickboxing,
kickboxing,
wrestling,
competition
dynamics,
mma.
You want to get thrown in your fucking head.
Go find her.
Max.
I want you in here,
man.
You Max.
Max.
Put this whole thing up.
Although you cannot see Max on the podcast
because of him.
Assault took place.
So I just want to say thank you.
Thank you Michael.
Rupert.
That was an awesome podcast.
A lot of fun.
It was very interesting.
We've got to learn a lot of shit.
Got To get into some squirrel magic or Fox
is a shocking.
It was scary.
It was thought provoking.
It was positive.
Even ultimately with all the doom and gloom,
I'm still positive.
There's a lot of good things happening now,
man.
They're coming out and all we gotta do is just speak to him to see him.
How did you choose the area where you decided to camp out up North California?
Oh,
I've,
I've had the privilege of traveling the world,
looking at sustainability and all the efforts that are taking place all over the
country to write and what I find in western Oma county,
it's the perfect climate.
That's where Luther Burbank settled.
It's the right culture.
There's a strong tradition of local food growing and permaculture and uh,
the kind of society I want.
And there's also a center of learning transition towns is a US headquartered
there and Richard Wineburg,
a lot of people who are part of the same effort are all living there.
So it's Kinda like a little genuine,
you know?
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
And how long have you been up there?
Uh,
we moved March 30th of this year.
I moved out of bed.
It's like,
yeah,
you don't want to be invested.
You don't want to be an advancement shits.
I have several friends that live in Venice,
like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Why would you live there?
And crazy.
That's a dangerous spot.
Dangerous.
10 of my advantage.
Advantage for,
for two and a half months.
Dennis.
Great parts about it.
But boys a spooky Los Banos yeah.
The guy who sail sail boats up and down to the western hemisphere.
This wild motherfucker took a sailboat from America all the way down to South
America.
Where did you go by himself?
Started Oregon Hood River,
Oregon.
And where,
where did you end up?
Middle of Columbia.
Got a little spicy.
They're kind of like,
what happened?
Well,
I can't.
It's a,
it's an interesting area.
It's a place where there's a,
a constant battle going on.
Yeah,
and the ethnic
ethnic traditions there are still strong and I stood out with the blonde hair.
Let's leave it at that and see I problems there.
Yeah.
Show up and start banging bitches on your sailboat now.
There was none of that.
You can't do that dude.
Then I going to take that.
No white boy shows up on a boat.
Is that what the problem was?
My lucky bastard.
No,
those were the problem,
right Brian that are adult and bit them in the balls or something?
No,
not talking about locals.
Wow.
Well thanks for hooking this up man.
This is a really fun part.
Thank you.
Good.
Let's do it again man.
I'm sure we could talked forever.
We'll do it again some time.
Definitely.
And if you're ever selling anything,
if you ever got a book that's coming out,
if you have anything,
please let me know.
Throwing out twitter.
We'll pump it up as much.
It's cool.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Hi everybody.
This is post podcast.
I'm Joe Rogan and that's everlast when the house pain or you can call him Whitey
Ford.
Don't call them Erica.
Pretend you know him.
Don't get stupid.
Don't get all goofy man and certain certain rules that apply when you have a
fake name like soulja boy,
you can't come up soulja boy and call him by his real name.
It's like disrespectful,
right?
Unless there's.
What's his name?
Does anybody know soulja boy's room that you've seen some of his new dances?
He has a new dance contests.
You learned his dance.
If you do it the best are going to give you $100,000.
Oh,
who's this kid getting?
It's kind of bread.
He's getting by like a $50,000,000 check everyone gets,
but listen to your records or not get your money.
Just has a good printer.
Is Printing money
stacks and it's like,
did he make it a lot of money?
He's selling out concerts.
He's.
He's huge.
He's got like,
who knows how many million twitter followers now,
how many millions do you have?
Got a lot of twitter followers.
Right?
So he's got all that going on.
He's got,
you know,
he's selling out all these arenas,
if you're selling out arenas,
you haven't going a lot of fucking money.
Why of people come and see soulja boy concerts that I can't think of selling out
of the,
out of the loop,
man.
I'm sorry.
I've got to think of selling out pretty big places.
Soulja boy's got killed.
So when you bought $50,000,000 jets that what he did,
he bought a $50 million dollars for his birthday.
That was like the last news I heard about it,
but maybe he lines and maybe got like conditions like partnership,
fractional ownership.
One of those things and shit.
Boy,
Jay Jay apparently with that stupid fucking that Superman,
which is catchy,
but I really $50,000,000 jet for that song,
but it's amazing.
How do you do it?
Seems like it's having a good time.
He'd selling out like where?
Like the staples center.
I don't know.
We have to,
we have to look up to be honest about that,
to give a good statement,
but you know it.
You know what he's pushing those that he's having a good time.
You know what,
he's pushing this,
he's out there,
they're sociable and he's having fun.
He's got his pants down here and because pants like sagging,
like literally down to his dick and he's silly.
It's a silly boy.
Completely unthreatening skinny nonviolent.
Not talking about beating anybody up and just catching on like wild fire,
you know,
and just found a niche family,
like some area that people want to hear.
Not that I'm,
I haven't bought it.
Well you're not,
you're not a 17 year old black girl,
girl,
girl thing.
Well there's a lot of girls that like,
I'm just pretty boy.
That's this thing.
Pretty much swag.
And you love him.
I think he's having a good time.
I wouldn't mind hanging out with that dude.
There you go.
Put it wasn't loaded.
Boy.
Joe Rosa and I hope it's front of me.
Seems like a friendly guy.
He sounds like he has no complaints.
Like you're pouty lips.
So the dollar jets.
And how long can we keep this up?
A little bit behind the music.
You guys still touring as a house of pain?
We did like a 20th anniversary thing this year.
Oh yeah.
Six months.
I told her I get to do more of those.
Um,
that's like a kiss thing where you can keep doing that.
You keep bringing that back it out every once in a while.
Get happy around St Patty's Day.
And do like a week's worth of data.
You do it in Boston or if we did well we did
kind of big return thing we did was Dana's party.
Yeah man,
I was pissed.
I had a date already booked,
a comedy date already booked and it was St Patrick's Day in Boston with the
house of pain.
It must have been a lot of concussions that night.
Not really because it wasn't.
Know if I would've done anything over,
I would have opened it up to the.
It wasn't,
it was like a Dana private of.
Oh yeah,
it was fun.
It was a good time.
Everybody was fine,
but I'm saying like the knuckleheads didn't get in last night,
but we did one.
We did one last year.
That's when.
Yeah.
Your music is synonymous with bar fights,
you know,
it's fun.
Yeah.
Yeah,
everybody wants to die,
right?
Yeah.
That was the first video where I was like,
cool.
That was cool to have a quarter Irish,
Irish last name was cool to be a little bit of Irish.
Cool Dude.
He had always been cool at certain neighborhoods,
but now it's National Celtics Jerseys flew off the shelf.
That was just really awesome.
White boy shit.
Tuesday.
I've always been a laker fan that trips people out,
but I wore the Celtics Jersey because it was the Larry Bird thing like,
yeah,
we the bed
bad,
baddest white boys and the girl that was that statement was hilarious.
He used Larry Bird is here.
That's right.
As you're the baddest white dude.
I love when he used to come to those three point contest and you would go or
who's coming in second.
All right,
let me just show up.
You got to scale those three throw contest and he goes,
who's coming in second?
First Bitch reading streets all day,
man.
Thanks for doing the podcast was awesome.
Say,
Oh gee,
everlast on twitter.
Hey.
Hey everybody.
We're post podcasts where my pal Brian.
That's right.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I am in the,
uh,
in the cage right now,
Joe Rogan.
We had a good time today.
What's important?
Yeah,
a lot of weird shit and most importantly brined cow and let us know he's going
to go back to training.
A lot of people say,
Hey Brian,
I'm,
you know,
train them more.
But I train a lot now and just to roll it ties up a lot.
A lot of stand up.
Yeah.
But meanwhile I,
if I get punched in the nose,
I got sucks.
It's bad for you.
Can't really transfer over for me and let's be honest,
but it's just getting your nose broken.
It's such a huge pain.
That deck or it comes to going to the doctor and get straight to.
Yeah.
I have a friend who had a tongue ring and his tongue ring somewhere else through
sleeping.
Cracked a couple of his teeth.
So they had extracted teeth,
so he lost,
like to have a side teeth because of a tongue ring.
You can't stop shooting when by the way,
I broke my nose and I can or I knocked my teeth out.
We have what he did,
but they give you like fake teeth for a little bit.
It's really to do that.
Yeah.
They have to shut down production.
They could do it pretty quickly I think give you like a little little bread,
but I don't want to fuck dude,
that's a drag.
I do love training or I miss it a lot.
So I've been doing it a little bit and it's been fun.
But didn't you have like a crazy concussion?
Yeah.
What you thought you were going to last time?
I.
I've framed heavy.
Yeah.
I don't care.
You know now.
Now I don't care.
Now he's just kind of keep you keep doing it and you do it at your own pace and
you can learn a lot better now.
I'll get better now because I don't care.
Because you're not a nut either.
You were spastic.
I remember when you rolled with Sergio Colon and you've got so rough with him
and he fucking head butted head about me and broke my nose.
Yeah.
What did you let you do that?
I was taking a.
well,
because I was in there taking guys down cause I was,
I was arrested wrestler,
right.
So I'll take these guys.
I was like,
ah,
you don't know him that I was doing like weird shit that doesn't work against
wrestlers,
but they'd never done stuff.
Like one time I took a guy here I can't remember and I ducked under and pulled
this way and just flew over and he didn't know what to do.
So I was doing really obnoxious shit and Sergio and I got in this thing and I
didn't have any respect for just do to,
I didn't know anything and he kind of,
he kinda,
we went against the wall and he was trying to take me down but he didn't know he
wasn't doing a lot of take downs or something and I threw my hand into his
fucking that was just to tick.
And he goes,
he took it out of the way and he's like.
And then we went to the ground and the little bucket and he put me in an arm bar
but he let me go.
He would have killed me,
but I was too stupid to know the difference.
It happens.
A lot of.
Gosh,
there's a lot of guys to get real personal chat though.
You don't mean I don't care.
I mean,
but.
But I just got excited and I've seen people dig into people's eyes.
Would like hands accidentally tap and they're like as the defending but like
digging noxious.
What are you doing man?
Just tasks.
Not a war,
which already we'll do a lot of creepy shit.
No more taste stuff,
buddy.
Keep finding more gay thing stuff.
The fact that you might have sucked on Barris cock on the outside about 30 or 40
years.
What's on the outside?
It was a mock suck.
Let's be honest.
The whole area story though.
That was funny as it gets,
right?
Yeah.
When you go start your own podcast.
I'm going to start my own podcast next month.
Next week,
next week.
Next week.
We're doing it.
And you're my first guys.
Okay.
What would was going to be called?
It's going to be called the questions with Brian.
Questions with Bryan County sharks in questions.
I'm going to ask you questions and it's going to be all kinds of names.
Should be in the beginning.
Brian Cowen questions,
Ryan,
count your neighbors.
Importance Barton.
Countless questions.
That's it.
That's it right there.
Brian Collins.
Questions.
Beautiful.
It's.
We just got.
We just got the nail.
My,
your name is on the front of it.
That's really important that people know who the fuck you are,
right?
Yeah.
Well you've been tagged teaching me about.
I'm so lazy with that stuff,
but it's important because you know,
you want to get your.
It's,
it's fun to get an audience and in connection with those people to,
you know,
not just the podcast but twitter,
all that stuff.
You know,
you're interacting with people.
I'm really anxious and people really appreciate it.
Which,
so it surprised me.
I had no idea that so many people listen to your podcasts and I did it when I do
the show and people come up to me and they,
and they,
they thanked me here.
They say I listen to on the Rogan podcasts.
It's a powerful medium.
You know,
it's amazing.
We've never had anything like it before in human history as far as we know,
the idea that you can just have a pirate radio show and it's legal for now.
It's been talking about that before.
It's illegal.
Brian Sopa,
he thinks so motherfuckers,
they're going to say,
yeah,
we got to get bigger and bigger to the point where they can't stop it.
The ceiling.
Hope there are big enough to the point where when it rolls around,
it's too big stuff.
I mean,
that's exactly right.
You've got to.
You've got to figure out.
They want to pass legislation.
It's going to make the problem better.
Probably not.
Well,
there's also people that are interested in launching their own satellites for
communication and for Internet.
If they shut down the Internet.
There's private companies that are talking about doing that.
The Tesla Guy,
in fact,
who started paypal,
he has a company that launches a private satellites,
so they're going to come up with a way to keep the internet going no matter
what.
At this point in time.
It's too many companies like,
like Google's antisocial,
right?
Aren't they?
I mean,
come on,
man.
If Google's anti,
so for that is also because you can technically under that law,
hold them accountable for things and they're like,
you know,
my,
my website would essentially have to shut down.
I couldn't.
I couldn't keep all those.
A toric stream.
By the way,
we've done just fine without government intervention.
We've done just fine so we don't need.
We don't need a yet another group of government laws.
It's so gross.
Everything is regulated nowadays is stand up comedy and fucking that's it.
There's not much.
There's not much that make sense anymore.
It's weird.
We're in a really weird time where they're,
they're scrambling,
like you said,
40,000 laws.
They passed last year.
Human beings figure themselves out.
They can.
We can.
We can get along.
And by the way,
one of the other things is that that human beings actually and even primates are
very good at cooperation and working together.
Like we said,
there's always going to be people who do the wrong thing,
but for the most part,
if you look at the way society is working,
if you look at the way people actually behave in in catastrophes like tsunamis
and things,
they don't panic and running the streets.
They actually work together and help each other.
They get very calm and they start helping each other and they become very
communal
social and that's how we've survived through the millennia by cooperating with
each other,
by forming societies,
by forming rules for those Saturdays,
and we didn't need these huge central bodies organizing and running,
instructing the money from the system.
You twats I see half my money.
One love bitches does squad.